好的各位领导
今天跟各位领导分享
这个AI工具是完全免费没有限制
并且支持三种视频模型的使用
包括图片生成
视频生成
都是完全免费
没有任何限制
拿来就用
开箱就用
连登录都不需要
对吧
这个工具非常好用
比如我们来看一下
生成的一个视频
就是直接一个小狗女人化演唱歌曲
站在喜马拉雅山上
我们来看一下效果
如果你有太多的反乱
天堂了就不暂停去往前走
怎么样各位领导
就是说它这个
支持好几个模型的一个视频生成
并且还有图片生成
那么这个工具是什么
就是这个VEO AI FREE
就是这个工具
它是完全免费的
连甚至你都不需要点击它的广告
那么在介绍这个工具之前
还是要感谢一下
分享这个工具的大哥
就是这个Kims
大哥给我分享的这个工具
让我做个视频给各位领导分享出来
非常感谢这个大哥
那么在介绍这个工具之前
还是一样的
介绍一下咱们自己的一个东西
就是咱们的这个新源
AI的一个电报订阅频道
如果大家有电报的话
一定要订阅一下咱们这个电报订阅频道
会分享最新的一些AI的好用的工具
和实时的信息
并且有很多这种越狱的东西
我不方便做视频
咱们就直接随手在咱们这个电报订阅频道上面
进行一些分享了
包括大模型的越狱
还有免费的大模型
还有等等
很多好的东西都会在这个电报上面
进行一个分享出来
有很多可能是你花钱都买不到的这个东西
所以说大家如果有电报订阅号的话
一定要点击这个订阅
它会比视频更新的更加及时
更加好更加快
所以说大家一定要点击这个电报订阅
这也就是说给自己打广告
好那么话不多说
我们去来看一下这款AI工具
这个AI工具就是我们可以打开它这个主页面
我们直接打开一个主页面
我们来打开这个
veoaifree.com
它实际上是这样的一个
就是我们可以直接点击这个
这个
所有的这个视频生成模型我们都可以进行使用包括所有的这个图片生成模型我们就直接点击这个all video 这个生成点击之后我们就来到这样的一个一面啊就是说他目前来看啊
我们可以给他翻一下
或者说是不翻也行吧
因为实际上咱们还是用的是这个
字节跳动这个C dance 2.0这个模型
因为这个模型是目前
视频生成效果最好的对吧
比起他不单单是有这个视频生成模型
还有这个视频转录的
就是从通过将这个YouTube的视频转换为这个文本
包括还有这样什么文本生成视频
包括由图片生成AI视频等等
很多非常多的这个工具
全部都是免费的
但如果像我们个人使用大部分可能都会使用咱们这个
Cdance2.06视频我们只需要点击下面这个查看更多就是C帽
打开C帽之后我们就可以利用这个模型来进行一个视频的创作
这个设置这里面可以根据自己需求
点击生成视频的数量
一次最多是生成两个
之后我们就一般选择一个
玩意义选择生成视频的一个尺寸
选择完之后我们就输入提示词
点击提升或者不提升
就是说根据我们自己需求
是否需要提示词的扩展
之后我们点击生成就可以了
比如说你看我这边
让他生成的是什么
一个小狗
你人话演唱歌曲道乡
站在喜马拉雅山上
点击生成之后
他就帮助我们生成了这样的一个视频
是8秒钟的一个视频
他是支持的时长
是大约是在4到8秒钟之间
他说是这么说的
我们往下可以看到
这里通常为4到10秒
所以说这边
并且它是1080p的视频
所以效果非常好
其他的模型就不见得大家使用了
因为效果没有这个视频好
包括你看我这边用的是
谷歌的VO这个模型
也是我们点击这里
VO3.1的这个模型
来进行一个视频的创作
我也是一样的一个小狗女人话站在灶台前面炒菜的样子
当然这个也是8秒钟的一个视频
效果呢也就是一般啊也是一般没有这个
C dance这个模型效果那么好
但是具体是真的还是假的咱们不用管他了
因为他能免费给我们进行一个ai视频的创作就是非常好但是有一个问题是什么你看我这边通过图片转换视频他就一直是这样在刷新百分之百的生成不出来
不知道是为什么
可能用的人太多或者怎样
但是咱们用文本生成视频是一点问题都没有的
包括你看也可以用Groke的大模型
就Groke AI来进行一个视频的生成也是一样的
同样的提示词
它也是文本生成视频是一点问题没有的
但是这个图片生成视频
我这边测试了一个
他确实是一直在这样刷新
不知道为什么
我看我刷新一下
他一直不生成出来
估计还是可能
对于这个图片转视频的效果
没有想象中那么好
有可能会失败
这个时候大家可能需要多次尝试
包括他还可以进行一个图像生成
你看图片生成
但是他说是他用的是
nano banana
这个大模型
但实际上他用的是
image4的模型
并没有nano banana
那么强
没有那么强
我们看到让他生成一个日本美女在东京街头
举着一个白板
写着这个新年AI好6
他生成出来的效果完全是对于文字
完全是不行的
就是不行
所以说他的这个模型不是nano不nano pro模型
而是这个谷歌的image4这个模型
这个模型就是没有那么强
但是对于我们免费生成图片来讲
也是非常棒的一个模型
非常好
就是说我们点击这上面一排
都可以进行一个使用
包括图片生成视频
或者图片生成图片
这个都可以
我们比如点击所有的图片生成
它就是nano不nano
还有图片转成
卡通啊
照片转绘画呀等等等等之类
也是非常多
实际上这都是提示词的
功能嘛
我们只要提示词写好了
它这些生成的所有的这些功能
都可以进行一个使用
非常强
最关键是这个工具
目前来看是完全免费的
不需要我们任何钱
并且没有任何限制
除了像是我们刚才介绍的这些功能
实际上它用法也是非常简单
我还是最后给大家做一个总结就是我们只要选择了任意一个比如说所有的视频生成模型咱们以Groke举例或者说是Cdance举例
我们只要点击查看更多之后
它每个模型针对的除了视频生成器
还有图像生成器
所以说我们用Groke的时候
可以不但用它视频生成
还可以用它的图像生成
只要点击之后就可以进行一个生成
也是非常强大
而且呢,它是支持,也是这里有个设置的标志嘛
对吧,我们点击设置标志,可以根据自己需求选择这个模型
包括这个图片的尺寸,还有一次生成
图片的这个数量啊,一次可以生成四张或一张
而且还是完全免费
除了包括你看Groke,对吧,我们这个Cdance
就是字节跳动这里面也是一样的,你看这个视频创作
图像生成,我们点击设置,它也是一样的
2.0对不对,然后包括这个View3.1
我们还是一样的,来打开一个新的窗口
也是一样也是可以进行一个图片的创作
实际上主要还是用的是这三个模型
我们随便选择一个适合自己的就可以了
所以说这个市面上主流的
这样的一个视频生成模型和图片生成模型
我们都可以通过这个工具完全免费无需登录的进行一个使用
非常非常强吧
因为他不需要登录相当于我们拿来就用了
虽然说他们这些
图片生成的工具可能不是世界上最顶尖的
但是我觉得对于我们日常使用来说
也已经够了
非常好
那么这里呢我还是要感谢
还是要感谢这个Kinis大哥提供的这样的一个工具
让我们每个人都可以通过这个工具
白嫖使用这个视频生成模型和这个图片生成模型
非常方便非常好吧
但是具体什么时候失效咱们不好说
所以说趁着现在免费的时候
大家有需要的话就赶快使用
防止到说失效的时候大家就是使用不了了
那么就得不偿失了
好吧
那么今天的视频就简单的跟各位领导分享一下这款工具
使用起来非常简单和方便
无需登录点击打开就可以使用
好吧
那么我们下视频再见
希望大家点个订阅
未来会更新更多的这种免费的AI工具给大家
那么我们下个视频再见